*the footsteps of about 50 kids running to a hole*
Hi, welcome to "KIDS".  Uh...
*quiet chuckle*
*a longer quiet chuckle*
You've made a mistake.
You shouldn't give me this power.
You shouldn't give me this power!
If your intention was to disturb me, *laughing* you are so mistaken.
Anyway,
Welcome to "KIDS".
You remember Plug n' Play?
Flashback Mark: "Put one prong in-"
Yeah that game uh...
That was effectively a nightmare...
Flashback Mark: "Then you shake it all about-
This is that game's kid brother.
Whee!
He he he he
*weird Mark noise*
Alright sorry *chuckle*, this shouldn't be uh...
I probably shouldn't find this as humorous as I do...
But I DO.
*more weird Mark noises*
Oh!
And then there was one.
Did that game do that intentionally, or is that just me?
Okay, whatever.
BOInkus
Whee!
Alright. So this is "KIDS". Um...
If you DON'T remember Plug n' Play
It had this.
Oh...
And then I saw this game and I'm like, "Oh, yeah! This will be-
This'll be a trip."
You know, the game costs two bucks
But I think it really gets you on the therapy over the long
*Breathe*
time that you'll have to recover from it.
So
Am I supposed to catch these... people?
*gasp*
I gotcha!
I got ya!
*laughing* I got-
Uh- oop-
UH-
Hey!
Oh- oop-
Now this...
*laughing* This is what
This-
In the many years,
that games have been perfected,
who knew that in 2019 we would reach the peak
of gaming prowess?
Uh-
*laughs*
Hey buddy!
Alright see ya. Goodbye.
This um...
Oh.
Well, you're dead. I can only imagine.
*laughs*
Hello?
Oh, hi!
Hey, how ya-
Uh oh
Okay, I thought you were coming up to punch me as hard as you could.
I would not have been surprised.
Hi! Hello!
"Hello."
Oh.
*punch*
I KNEW IT!
"Hi."
*laughs* I KNEW IT!
I KNEW IT! *laughs*
Alright.
Who's gonna punch who this time?
This way-
UHM
WELL
I dunno know if that's the best way...
Hey kids!
Hey, you crazy kid-
You get away from that pit, you!
Hey, come on now!
Op-
Whop- yep.
I tried to warn ya
Ooh
Wait what?
"This way."
I'm soOoRry?
"No, that way."
No, that way, okay.
Alright.
Well, you BOTH can be right.
Ah well, if your friend jumped in a giant hole on the ground,
would you do it too?
Yeppers peppers!
Alright.
Oh...
Well, I hate that.
Am I supposed to do something about the dangly penis?
No.
Alriight.
UH!
Ha ha ha!
Oh god...
Nah.
Okay, alright, I'll see you around.
Hey, it's been fun,
but I-
I'm gonna go now...
*heartbeat*
Oh boy...
Uhm...
Alright.
Hu-
Huauuh.
I might actually vomit.
Oof.
I don't know why that's...
Whew.
Ough.
I'm, like, having a physical reaction to this.
Mm.
Okay, I'm fine
I'm fine.
Ohhh...
HU HA
*sniiiiif*
Oh! I'm still supposed to participate in this activity, huh?
It's a group activity.
Uh- here we goo.
Huh huh huh
*sad Mark noises*
*breathes*
AHHHH
Ah he-
I'm
un
com
fy! He he.
Are YOU uncomfy?
I'M uncomfy hehehehe.
Get
down
there.
I don't like that I have to force you down.
Here we goes, SPEED DEMON!
WHEEE!
Here we go.
Now that uh oh-
No, wait. No, that's a butthole.
I know a butthole *laughing* when I see one.
THAT'S a butthole!
That very clearly has been leading up to a butthole...
THAT'S a butthole.
No one can tell me that's not a butthole.
Don't like that the music's kicking up.
Here we go!
Three! Two-
The only way through a butthole is violent reentry.
Here we go!
*crazy Mark noises*
That's a-
*wheeze*
Fuck off.
Just-
don't.
Let me die!
Hey, you stuck? What's wrong?
Hey, come on, now!
Come on!
Oh you can do it-
UUGGHH
Oh god...
This is the worst.
It's the worst
*bap*
Oh you crazy kids.
Ah, come on now.
How 'bout you?
Yeah, you get up.
There we go.
Goodbye.
Yeah, you best run away after that experience.
If you lived from that, you would run.
Uh uh
*monkey Mark*
IGOTTAGETOUTTAHERE
IGOTTAGO
IGOTTAGO!
GARhG
Alright, and then get up.
Hey!
Oh-
Okay goodbye.
Ohhh nooo.
*whap*
Oh
Boy I hate it.
*whamp* *whomp* *whap*
I hate it.
All right
You know what?
W- play two- play two at this game!
Two plays! At this game!
TWO! This game is two player!
TWO can play at this game!
Hey, wait, don't.
*the footsteps of many children*
No, don't. Don't do it. Don't.
Don't, dooon't, don't do it.
Hey, wait, they're all looking at me,
they're not looking at the hole,
they're all looking at me
I don't like that.
You get in that hole.
You get in that hole!
Ooodledoodele
Hehehehe
That's too satisfying!
Oh, what?
"This way."
Dis way?
"No, that way."
"Agreed."
"No-"
"No, this way."
"Yes."
"No, that way."
Uh-huh. Okay, which way?
"No, this way."
"No, that way."
*overlapping "no's"
Okay, you guys don't know shit, do you?
Okay, I just need to point you all in the-
There we go.
Oh look, you're-
"Agreed."
Uh huh.
Ahhhh, there we go.
Du du du du du du du du du
Nice orderly line, I like it.
Ladadooo
Ladadeeee
Oh yeah,
you, you saw what they were doing
and you decided that was a good idea.
That's-
That's wonderful, thank you for this...
experience that I'm
enjoying here-
Oh! Oh am I- Am I a part of this?
Oh am I doing something here?
Oh, do I have to-
Hey, wait, whoa! don't- Uh what?
*small wheeze laughter*
I convinced TWO people!
I'm a hero!
Hang on, wait.
There we go. That's what I'm talking about
Just divert the herd.
Oh!
Is this like one of those things at VidCon where there's a
spicy new influencer and...
the crowd is just running to get a piece of their hair?
Oh...
Yeah, you stupid go up not down.
You stupid idiots. Come on now
Alright. All is as it should be-
"Hey, where'd you guys go?!"
*laughing at himself*
"Hah! You idiots!"
*laughs*
"I'm not a fool like you guys! You're goin' the wrong way!"
"All o' you are dumb, and I'M smart!"
"Hah!"
I'm sorry.
Ahhhhhh
IN the hoOoOle!
It seems like I just
*laugh*
Made these guys go aroOoOOOH
Alright you distracted me by space.
You knew the word that I liked, and it's space.
This isn't space is it?
You tricked me this is NOT space,
this is the opposite of space!
OH NO! it's the ocean!
AH I WAS DUPED
I'VE BEEN DUPED
NO!
*laughing* Not the ocean's butthole!
Not Davey Jones's butthole!
Here I go...
Ope-
Welp...
I hate it.
Here we go again.
Hmm, you know-
you know the developer like
found a way to do this mechanic and was like,
"Ah, yeah!
Perfect!
EXACTLY what I was hoping for!
I wanted this!
This is the best!"
You know-oh, no, that's not right
*laughing* What's going on here?
All right, some kind of...
Siamese twin digestive system or something?
Get down there.
Just-just go faster.
I've already gotten used to this.
I don't LIKE that I've gotten used to it-this
but I've gotten used to this.
Alright, well someone's constipated.
Oh God..
Don't you hate these LA traffic jams?
It's just the gosh-darn worst
Get down thereee.
Uh-
And here we-
Here we go!
*wheeze*
Getoutgetoutgetoutgetout
*sad laughter*getoutgetout!
Oh no!
No!
GET OUT GET OUT!
*wheeze*
*actual laughter*
GEOUT
*breathe*
GET OUT GET OUT GET OUT!
I hate it...
I hate it!
AHHHHHH
*splat*
I HATE IT
Get up...
Run!
NOOO
I know where you are.
Oh, what the hell?
What?
What, are you gonna fight me?
Huh? You're putting up your dukes?
Hey, you can't put up your dukes to me!
I'm unDUKEable
You couldn't possibly be duking me.
Don't even THINK about it
Don't even SUSPECT about it.
Alright
WHOOO
Oh.
"I won't do it."
Do it!
Come on, do it!
"You do it."
"No, you do it."
"No, you."
*No, you's overlapping*
"Alright."
*wheeze*
Oh, okay! Maybe you shouldn't have volunteered for this.
Whoa! You are fast!
Am I supposed to stop you for any reason,
or should I just let you careen off into the abyss?
Because I feel like
I want to do that
and I don't want to participate in this.
As I've mentioned before,
I don't feel like I should participate.
Alright, come on.
Yeah, lets go!
C'mon swim!
Swim for it!
Come on, you know you want to!
C'mon, swim!
Swim to the butthole!
C'mon!
Uh...
Are we supposed to swim up maybe?
Ooooh I click n'
Ooooh
Well!
Alright, then!
If I didn't know I was gonna be such a trendsetter
maybe I woulda gone first sooner!
Oh, you idiots! You're all goin' the wrong way!
I'm goin' the right way!
You stupid fools, don't you know? *laughs*
It is a very satisfying.
I do like it.
Like the uh...
The elastic nature of the group.
It's filling out pretty thick and heavy.
Dat's good I gue-
And- Oh!
You idiots! Heh heh
Dis is the way out!
Don't you know up from down?
Up
Apparently
*ploop*
*people singing*
Aw, that's pretty
*more singing*
Okay, that's pretty cool. I like that.
*even more singing, but prettier*
I like that.
Now it's getting a little cacophonous.
*even MORE singing, but apparently cacophonous*
Whoa!
Very nice.
Okay.
Or not-
*clap*
Blap!
*chuckle*
Bla-
*laughs*
It's the world's worst
applause.
Like, this is a nightmare for me at, like, a panel.
Just like I say something like,
"We're gonna do great stuff! Ah, thank you!"
And it's just-
*clap*
*wheeze*
*quiet laughter*
It's so
*wheeze laugh*
There's something really- really funny 'bout it.
*clap*
Aw- I was hoping it would do it in the order I did it.
I wanted to do the wave!
Oh, hello.
*ploop* *ploop* *ploop*
OOOOHH
*laughs*
Oopsie poopsie!
Did I do-
*laughs*
Did I doopsie woopsie that?
Alright.
An- welp. Let's just head right in.
I don't think there was any other way to go.
There's some like sepret-secret Easter Egg in this game
where it's like, "Man, why does it-"
and the developer's like,
"Why does everyone keep goin' for the butthole?!
That's the BAD ending!
Where's the good ending?! Where it's like a field of flowers!
How come no one saw that!?
*chuckle*
God, these freaks!
These-
*laughs*
These freaks just kept goin' straight for the butthole!
I can't believe it!"
Right, well
you can't trick me!
Haha!
Stupid!
Haha stupid!
Haha, you're stupid!
Oh, yeah! Even Steven!
Ah-
Oh-
Well-
Not even.
Shoosh!
Hello again.
*boom*
Boomp! Alright, then. That's-
That's-
Oh, God-
Yeah, I would be scared if-
If someone just fell out of the ceiling...
Out of a-
Sky-
Butthole-
That's pretty cool.
Okay, THAT'S pretty cool.
That's VERY satisfying.
There's something VERY satisfying about that.
Oh...
That's pretty-THAT'S pretty satisfying.
That's pretty cool.
I gotta admit, that's cool.
I like that.
That's pretty cool.
Hey, why are you chasing me?
Hey, don't chase me!
Hey, c'mon, don't chase me!
C'mon, what're you
OOH I'm gonna getcha!
Okay. Imma getchu
Imma getchu
OOOOHHHHH
Imma get-
I'm gonna getchu x3
LEEDLE LEEDLE
OOOOHHHHH
Alright, you lucky I slowed down for a second there.
All right, fine.
Aww, c'mon!
Come on! Don't chu wanna know where I came from?
Don't you wanna know the way to the hole?
That's the worst thing to yell as you're running at people,
"DoN't yOu WaNNa knOw tHe WaY TO tHe hOLe?"
C'MON LEMME SHOW YA!
IT'S A REALLY COOL HOLE!
YOU'LL LOVE IT!
C'MON!
Oh, okay.
Goodbye.
"Whoa, what a weirdo."
"Ha, those idiots!
Not goin' near my hole!
Alright, anyway.
*gasp*
I'm tired."
*laughs*
Or dead.
Might be dead after everything that hapened.
I-I guess you might be-
Ah, well-
Hey, c'mon!
Let's g-
Uh oh.
I don't wanna do that.
Go scooch over there.
Tuck you in for bed.
Goodnight!
Smooch
Get outta here...
Get outta here!
Nah-
Nah!
Get outta here!
Alright, fine
Get-
*laughing* Whoooah
*laughs*
What the hell?
I didn't know I could do that!
Shoom!
Shoom?
Ah
okay.
Time for the epic slam dunk-
shoo shoo shoo shoo
ZA BOOM!
That felt good
Aaaaaand
Nope?
Oh, it's clappy time again.
Cool.
Great.
You guys are so coordinated, I really appreciate that.
Okay
Alright, cool.
Eeeuuuhh
THE WAVE
IT'S THE WAVE!
I was hoping for that!
You guys are weird.
Nah you freaks.
These guys are a little weird.
Alright and
BAAAAACK
Like I'm all for...
Surreal.
"Yes."
"Agreed."
"That way."
*overlapping agreements*
Uh huh.
Is it really that way?
"No, this way."
OOH YOU'RE GONNA BE-
"Alright, that way."
Allllright
*laughs*
Yeah, I tried it, it-
Woaaaah
Alright, GO GO GO
IN SQUADS (what?)
GO GO GOOO
Just you
NOW ALL OF YOUU
I do love the crowd mechanics,
I think that's really interesting.
It's a fascinating thing.
Just a ton of independently animated things!
I mean there's probably a trick to it, but that's really cool.
It's a cool concept.
Like it-it's just reaching into the depths of imagination-
Now everyone into the hole!
Everyone stop being all
M-metaphorical about,
"GET IN THIS HOLE!"
GET
IN
THAT
HOLE!
Get in-
CHOIR, SHUT UP!
GET IN THE HOLE
STOP SINGIN'!
IT WON'T STOP YOU FROM GETTING IN THE HOLE!
YOU GET IN THAT HOLE!
It puts the lotion on the skin!
Some Halo ass thing.
*Mark's awesome singing*
Fuckin' aliens in there like, "It's the prophecy,
It's come true,
the-the great beyond,
the path of the light.
The..
We're all gonna die, it's beautiful!
Transcendence whatever," whatever the thing was
that they said.
Hurry up, get in the hole!
Really gonna clog up your system...
Is this just one big...
Allegory for
Constipation or something like that?
You know, if you all pushed and shoved,
you could get in there a lot sooner.
Just so you know.
I guess they ARE.
They are pushing and shoving.
Oh that's weird.
Oh there they go.
Oh now they're REALLY gettin' into it.
Oh yeah, there they go.
Oh yeah, here we go.
Now this is what I've been talking about my entire life.
Oh yeah.
Circlin' the drain
It's weird how when things get on this scale
They look fluid.
It looks more like a liquid
and not necessarily just a bunch of individuals.
Which I guess maybe is the point.
Whew!
Alright!
That was great.
I'm assuming that's the- yep!
I am gonna have a really weird dream about this game.
I know that.
But,
that was pretty cool!
I think that was interesting!
That definitely was surreal,
and artistic!
I'm not one for, like, a lot of modern art,
but that's an experience!
And,
I think we all learned something today!
If you guys didn't learn the lesson
that is so very painfully obvious in this game
Then I'm sorry.
You, your, your IQ just not as
big brain as some of the other people here
I mean everyone
if you know what this game talk about write in comment
What moral was!
We all know it! We all agree! And if you faking, we know.
So don't be pretend like you don't understand moral lesson
behind "KIDS" here.
You too dumb
and we too smart to not know you not smart!
So, there we go. Who made this?
Mario Vaughn Rickenbach.
Oh, I have to scroll through 'em?
Interesting x6
Well done. Well done. I did like that a lot.
That was-that was fascinating
Very fascinating.
Ooh! you can replay your favorite *laughs* nightmare!
Visit it at any time!
Yay!
That was pretty cool. I will admit, that was pretty cool.
So.
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
If you want to play this for whatever reason
it's in the description below
I mean heck, support indie developers like this.
It's it's a cool experiment
and it's a surreal experience and it gets people talking
about what the hell this meant. So that's good.
So if you want to see plug and play it's in the description below.
If you want to see other weird and surreal games, I've got them in the description as well!
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always I will see you,
in the next video.
Buh-bye!